you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens everybody welcome back out
to the show floor at e3 2016 this is the
game spot co-op stream live we are here
hi I'm Craig from screw attack gets to
you the I said this earlier the inmates
have finally they've been given that
they given us the keys then we are
finally here oh thank first time in a
decade this is great nick is here from
ScrewAttack what's up we have Danny well
and you got everyone from gamespot knows
miss danni yeah yeah it was such an
international superstar it's crazy some
of them have like Irish blindness you
need us talk can I just hear you talk
for her yeah just just talk for a little
with your accent that's beautiful how
are you doing oh it's all coughs cuelga
00 a new mytouch granel you can do
aussie too that's upside and of course
we have Brian Baker okay beard has hit
the floor at e3 which is outstanding
okay gentlemen home III we are on a day
to technically freeeee are we yeah I
ever just feel that way I sure it's
funny cuz after like Monday people like
who won't eat three like I told you
there's like three days to go come on
yeah that's crazy all right so it is
Wednesday we are here I want to talk
about the biggest surprises of ok so far
now I want to we're gonna talk about
this game here a little bit but there's
that we actually have a poll question
for you guys for the viewers if you're
watching on the ScrewAttack youtube
channel you can click the little I in
the corner and we have a pole right
there talking about quake champions
which was a big surprise yeah and if we
want it we all know your thoughts so
quick champions does it a get you
excited be is it man or is it see wait
what you know like so we want to know
what you guys think so vote of the pole
we're gonna take a look at it and see
what you guys think about Blake
champions all right I know what touching
I'm in a minute but right now I think
the biggest surprise coming out of III
as a whole was not so much that
microsoft announced a console mmm it was
that they announced to consult right dad
come out within a year of each other all
right right you know let's talk about
that for a little bit right the idea of
what happened there so Danny we'll start
with you man sure um the slim makes
sense right like the Xbox one is if
they're talking about launching Scorpio
we're talking like a year and a half
from now yeah and they really need
something to like stem the tide on xbox
one sort of falling behind and I mean
there's no pair of great in or
whatsoever but it looks nice it's
apparently less loud it's forty percent
the size it doesn't have that big and
power block attached to any more I mean
I'm not really sure if anyone like cares
about 4k video or HDR gaming I think
maybe we will start to any years time
you do know I have a question ok with
somebody please explain to me and the
gentle viewer what HDR is right it's so
I was talking to Peter Brandon's like
our tech expert about this so you
remember high dynamic range in like an
hot like half like two lost coast when
you're just talking crazy words right
now you just watch the words fly over
his head so apparently it's not one
thing to do it like resolution or
anything like that it has to do with
like the value of like shadowing so like
how you look like the color black king
it like really black yes exactly it's
like the different pun tones of Buck
it's doing color more than resolution
yeah ok uh alright sounds good I think
you need a side-by-side problem baits
are like actually yeah like this like
when you can demonstrate it like on your
phone you have an iphone right I do you
know how there's that HDR option you're
taking a picture oh yeah you know look
at Nick get no can delete it with it you
can turn that on it'll take two pictures
so you can actually see the side by side
we need to do that we should do that
that's great ok so I 4k HD forget HDR or
is it crazy so it's smaller compact
doesn't have the power brick in it
that's just the xbox one s right and
then they're saying Scorpio is going to
be the most powerful console ever made
six teraflop so many teraflops so many
terrified on't even have six fingers on
my one hand I can't even count that high
is that the 2016 meme the sixth
teraflops all right I think so yeah
pretty shot an elder scrolls hype lady
yo oh yeah
I'll get her all right so plus all right
but just to overall thought like the
idea of them announcing you say you say
it's a good move you think it's a good
move you said Scorpio is good because it
shows people that the Xbox one has a
future because right now it's just it's
already like you mind the PlayStation 4
like it's it's it's you know were you
not talking about it's like it's the
third and the three horse race at my
worry though is that like what they're
talking about is saying like 4k gaming
virtual reality with like no holding
back like you can have a
two-thousand-dollar pc right now which
still struggles of 4k and which still
struggles it like you running virtual
reality games no like there's this kind
of an air of BS with that and obviously
they're like they're pushing it they're
saying look we're going to be doing
something that's better than sony's VR
like trust us and we're gonna have
really high resolution games trust us
but it's still just like an element of
smoke and mirrors with it I want to see
what the thing is so I'm like cautiously
optimistic about it but Ryan what about
you man I'm honestly I can see the
reasoning behind doing the two consoles
because you'll have Scorpio for the real
guys want the real high-end stuff and
then the S is a more budget friendly
people who've been waiting for a price
cut they're getting a better version but
another factor for me is this number of
times they said these games that they
bring it out also our cross platform to
Windows 10 and so I'm going I can spend
400 on like a new console or I can spend
400 on g-force 1070 and get everything
just the same yeah so why would I bother
applying console yeah that message is
going to be so different once that
console comes out because the like the
graphics world will have shifted again
so it probably won't have that same
impact yeah it's always changing man
that's the world we live in all right so
obviously I was a big surprise uh god of
war right yeah I mention that last
segment but it's the idea of when that
was announced when cradles came out from
the shadows Nick you kind of you had a
raging boner for that uh well it's
trying to hide that was my hope you the
guy's head in front of us you couldn't
hide that okay thank you for the visual
yah yah yah wordsmith Nick yeah I i
recently got a playstation 4 for black
friday because you know after e3 last I
was like okay now there's too many
exclus
games alpha saying I have to get one and
I've never cared about god of war before
like they had a god of war collection
for playstation 4 i believe but i was
never really interested in it there's
something about this god of war where
I'm like okay this one I can get behind
I don't know whether it's the setting or
the RPG looking elements to it or some
combination of all of it but I'm really
digging this one this one looks like
it's going to be a lot of funny you guys
are talking about the emotional story
before I kind of want to echo that I
feel the exact same way I like the
dynamic of the father and son where the
father is trying to teach the Sun how to
it'll be a hunter and all this stuff it
looks really cool okay um so yeah
everyone's stoked about God of War right
Brian when that when I was announced how
did you feel inside what what hit would
hit the cockles of your stomach well I
think the the Norse mythology Ali says
has been presented in media recently
look like before movies it's much more
aggressive than kind of like like the
Greek mythology as a whole so it seems
like they're really upping the ante of
the action they can do with the gods are
going towards and also from our
residents Sony fan back at ScrewAttack
sean has been saying recently apparently
this god of war game is what Jackie
wants to do for a long time really yeah
so now they're kind of getting around to
his original desires and you know it's
funny because I was thinking this as
they kind of showed the look of
everything at how it felt very Norse
there were rumors like a long time ago
that the next god of war would be you
know sent around Norse mythology as
opposed to Greek and Roman mythology I
think the other rumor was like Egyptian
oh really I think I'd heard that
somewhere but i use it was a case of
like the rumor coming to light it makes
sense you can oh yeah Transneft auto
style right the city different however
yeah I'm what's weird about this one is
that it's all so different like game
like oh yeah it's not a hack and slash
no it's okay that's that's another part
of reason why this appeals to me is hack
and slash has never been my personal cup
of tea so yeah denim jeans out of his
hands was really right weird it was cool
we'll see who knows he might come back
sure all right let's move on let's talk
about
okay we talk about res evil 7 last time
but specifically how that was announced
right yeah everyone off guard yeah did
you everybody watching that thing Nick
you were sitting next to me you and I
had a back and forth yeah you're sitting
there like this you just cover your ears
like a frightened child and casino my
four-year-old whatever he's scared she
covers her ears Oh probably got it from
you probably I didn't know I did that
but I and I am begging you leaned over
to me and you like I will never play
this game ever I will never play this
game in like like seconds into it hadn't
even been like 30 seconds in and less
less than 13 hours later I have a vm
baby you'd already going against your
word that's great no like the way they
revealed it was so smart because the
resident evil as of late has been
deviating so far away from horror yeah
like looking at resume evil 6 it was
like action out the body the people
people didn't respond very positively to
it they've been no they've never been
louder saying that they want it to come
back to horror and so they did right by
everybody revealing resident evil 7 the
way they did this just nothing but a
creepy atmosphere you don't even really
see characters like he all its first
person which is a first for resident
evil and when we were playing the VR
they said that this might be the only
time they do it yeah but I the game is
first person and just the the title
coming up was the best way to reveal it
by far they just see the roman numeral 7
and after like two seconds i might have
been able to be like oh that's resident
evil but then like right before my brain
made the connection they showed the full
logo and that's when everybody the
audience to started clapping like crazy
because do you want everybody by
surprise did you see the the japanese
biohazard logo and yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's not just japanese it's a European
to I really but it's yeah the american
title is resident evil 7 biohazard yeah
in in Europe it's bio hazards seven
resident evil yeah it's it's a neat
little way to kind of like bridge does
that tickle your fancy Brian man the
sound design alone hmm cuz you can throw
like any game that's like dark brownish
kind of brooding stuff but that sound is
absolutely made that presentation
but I was playing when I was playing it
a half I'm a big weenie as I was playing
it you walk around and you have your
headset on and I kept hearing door the
boards creak in rocky floor I gone to
Nina and I was like somebody's moving
what's moving uncle the guys comment was
it just you and then I'm like oh I'm
moving it's me and I you go in the
kitchen and there's cans on the ground
and you feel like you're tiptoeing
around you don't wanna make noise
because you don't want to get you know
you don't alert the whatever's out there
so oh my goodness scared okay crazy huh
alright next thing let's talk about um
probably the biggest question mark you
know you know in metal gear when
somebody's alerted and there's a big ! I
add it was like after watching the guide
approximation event yeah there was a big
there was a big question mark over
everybody's head after watching that and
this the idea Nick and I disagree on
this but for me one of the biggest
surprises I thought Kojima would come
out and be like here is my next project
it's metal Greer yeah and like is it
essentially the exact same game yeah
like they didn't do a like a ukulele or
a blood-stained where you know it's a
creator of some classic franchise and
they're making you know same basic thing
but just like different names and
characters and all that stuff this is
this doesn't look like it's gonna be
anything like Metal Gear the reason why
I created that's really amazing oh yeah
yeah baby around you put over your
shoulder turn around it's a buddy cop
movie you'd say you're naked guy with a
naked baby handcuffed to you this stop
or my mom this man this thought trailer
is going to have nothing to do with
whatever of the cake miss yeah they're
[ __ ] degrees the gameplay reveal is
gonna probably throw everybody for a
loop gonna be a Medicare game again well
made like I'd re but gopher apparently
humans already confirmed out there was
those five guys floating in the sky that
they're there the Luden's which is a
reference back to a book from the 80s
and basically kind of their their mo is
they they mess with people today they
experiment with them confident like the
worthy or not trying to evolve the
species
right so I guess the fact that like all
the kind of the dead creatures that were
out there in the world we're like failed
experiments for them yeah and like it's
is even like the oil baby thing is just
another result of their work so it's all
right Riley acknowledge all right Austin
ating like whatever it is it's yeah
whatever it is it sounds it looks great
yeah it's like well let's remember like
music videos in like the late 80s where
they were just doing just throwing [ __ ]
at the wall and seeing what stuck this
is like watching like like who else
would make this who else would lure game
of me look in norman reedus digital baby
nightmare for like five minutes
everyone's like what the cops I better
sit on the del Toro reveal let me go
somewhere in the background a bit better
than they better than the trailer was
just I told Craig this I just want one
time in my life to enter a room the way
Kojima did this is like orchestra
playing you know silhouette it and then
you know every foot step you take lights
up the ground everybody's you know a
party I just don't do that one time in
my life I want to see like the behind
the scenes when they like handed Norman
Reedus the like script for this thing I
was like I never ceasing you can have a
sorry yeah yeah and you're gonna cry
with this digital baby and it's gonna be
dead fish everywhere like you may be all
right the whole time if you see the
movie jr. that's you know normally
here's the thing we need you to take off
your clothes all right all right let's
talk about a game okay doom came out
recently yeah well are going crazy over
doom yeah if you're into that sort of
thing quake champion Bryan went crazy
over this Danny I saw you don't got this
this was a surprise you guys didn't
expect this yes in a post doom worlds
like okay right doom was great right
yeah so before you play doom did you
want it to touch quake man the way they
were just plodding along getting dune
even out like the stores in the first
place yeah I didn't know what to expect
with it anymore but like in the post
doom world you're like oh no they got it
the guy mark back like it's it's now
time to do and for like a good three
minutes of this trainer I was super
worried it was a MOBA cuz obviously um
pions in the name yeah yeah yeah like
they're doing some like this what guns
in and rocket launchers and lightning
guns and a bunch of like the weird c.t.r
characters
three are in it likewise right but it it
looks like it might be ability based and
also it kind of looks like there might
be teams which they tried once with team
arena and that wasn't too good but I'm
like cautiously optimistic about it
super crazy for them to start the
conference with it though like they just
went all right they go oh you know as I
you know the first thing I thought when
I saw quake champions I thought how long
int it until fatality the old bill never
comes out of retirement ready guys which
I think he's here by the way yeah
something he's pushing these days
alright so let's go to another another
kind of old-school title that's coming
back pray yeah brave pray wasn't out
that was interesting yeah I remember
like some years ago they had a trailer
for prey 2 and then nobody ever heard
from it again and then there's this it
looks totally different but it still
looks really cool um I never played the
other prey games but I know that
everybody who did is like really keeping
this one on their radar aim yeah we're
the secular yeah yeah yeah yeahs game
you're not singular no fault of yours
because this is like an absence your own
pc and xbox at the first person game
which like not that many people played
at the time like you feat the main
character was Tommy hawk a Native
American who gets sucked up by UFO while
he's listening to Blue Oyster Cult yep I
basically just like kareena space stage
like it's its memory did you buy him
yeah played a bit I'm your grand or dead
granddad is like your spirit animal yeah
[ __ ] weird scary it's gone why are
they calling this game pray but on the
surface Danny everything you said if you
wanted a Hollywood with that script
somebody would buy that story buddy
would buy that premise for sure I mean
you're right like he was at human hand
her over was hot that prey to demo with
like alien bounty hunter that look cool
that went then you know the drain the
history of prey has been kind of strange
no it's cool to see it hopefully finally
coming back with something real person I
just wanna go talk to the mat but that
whoever possessed samanther mission
statement to like revived or say salvage
all these yeah yeah that's franchises I
just want to go shake their hand cuz
wolf inside then doom do now quake now
pray
like dishonored is basically thief yeah
right you like it kind of looks like
maybe system shock yeah wait like
Bethesda's just like corner they figured
it out yeah I figured it out it's all
right uh sony okay first up I've seen a
lot of people on the online who either
love the sony press conferences or were
like it was alright i personally loved
it yeah you either loved it or you
weren't there pretty or you didn't watch
it yeah just redo I'm last year so many
had a phenomenal press conference this
year they followed up really strong
again I say one of the biggest surprises
for me was how Sony didn't say a whole
lot and just put their games do their
talking yeah which it was like I was not
I was talking to Nick I said it's almost
like going to him going to a movie and
just watching a bunch of previews hmm
and that's kind of what it felt like
yeah but previews where I I I kind of
got a slight roller coaster vibe to it
just because of the crowd would like all
go nuts together yeah it felt like like
everybody was just celebrating these
these games that they're revealing like
everybody's like with the kratos for
meals when not all really started for me
is the whole crowd just went nuts and
like I didn't like i said i don't really
play god of war i was never really a big
fan of those games before but even i was
feeling it in that moment yeah it was it
was something else for sure but yeah
just the nonstop slew of trailers i
think they had presenters come out like
a four times total total whole like 90
minutes to hours however longer the
conference was boy in no celebrities
yeah it was like kojima but but his
celebrity status comes from being a
developer so one of us yeah don't let
the game speak for themselves yeah you
know you talk about like okay so
Microsoft this year that they have
presenters I mean and the idea of what
Microsoft does every year it seems like
they want to put the focus on the people
who are developing the games so you put
a name or a face with the game itself
right and that's great right but at the
end of the day every year we leave this
and we go man Sony had a great press
conference and then you go Microsoft oh
it was all right you know I guess you
know depending on where you stand right
there's a lot of like I haven't
considered that but you're right there's
a lot of dem time between the demos on
the Microsoft sage because they're like
okay and he
his ex with game here is you know what
game I like there's an element of like
they got like verbally hype it up yeah
it's like every every press conference
skills they need to do that sony didn't
and i think it was just as effective if
not more which I'll tell you I'll tell
you this much one of the most
entertaining things about this III as a
whole is watching the nervous indie dev
hit the stage and try to sell their game
that's the one of the best things I love
everything about Microsoft they do that
better than anybody like this it's it's
outstanding i love it all right i don't
hit the yardi level of last year no no
you're not my timer yeah yeah i think
the game also is phenomenal all right um
okay let's let's talk about this though
and i've talked about this on twitter
quite a bit no I I don't understand why
Microsoft continuously allows every year
sony to be the book end of the two right
yeah Microsoft goes six hours later sony
goes and they have a chance to
essentially make everybody forgets about
what microsoft said i think that they
should go head-to-head WCW ever seized
on Monday Night war exactly and they go
head-to-head and save figure it out you
know I cannot tell you how much i would
love hate that absolutely hot I i I'd
want to be a boat I want to be keeping
track of both but I course i won't be
able to you gotta make people decide man
you got to make people think well before
I I I didn't have any power in any say
in what preference conference I went to
like this is the first time I got an
invite for sony this year and that's the
only one I got an invite to so it feels
kind of like flip of the coin look at
the job but man it that'd be an
interesting like alternate universe
where Nintendo and Sony and Microsoft
I'll just do their things at the same
food be amazing i would really
appreciate that I just want starting to
open their presentation with like Kaz
Hirai and Mark Carney riding a tank up
to the Galen Center Ernie or cerny
because we had this conversation at fun
house pickets Ernie mr. nice attorney
all right sorry all right last one we
got about a minute left all right and
this probably the biggest surprise for
me which I don't know why it happened
why nobody told that lady at the
Bethesda press conference shot Oh
was probably his mom yeah or later on
that was his mom I mean she was going so
trapeze she was because its articles
online sand there is like the elder
scrolls online Bethesda they should be
they should be like out reaching out to
her for super enthusiastic about yeah
where we were it was that elder scrolls
hype lady was the hashtag that was
getting thrown around and a hapless yeah
it afterwards a bunch of people started
like sending flicka's I started like
going on about it and then people like
started sending me info from inside of
Bethesda bag so apparently there was a
group of about 20 ESO like super fans
that they invited we're sitting around
there okay right next to the microphone
yes so I think literally is one of them
lost the run of themselves and would not
stop oh man I mean it's really endearing
cuz the guy who went up was kind of felt
a little bit like all right I know some
of you don't care video so whether and
then he have this like this pack in the
crab they were just like a laughing at
all oh yeah they were straight literally
as a dog boy crazy last one to go thank
you guys so much for coming on stage as
great as always next Brian knows when
you get find them all on a scooter
attack and Danny of course sons you know
here I can try to anyhow to be here
today yeah you gotta you're the guy with
the with the leash making making sure we
don't say too many bad words so coming
up in just few minutes we're gonna talk
about the excitement of Microsoft we
talked about so many a few minutes ago
we're gonna rank our excitement for
Microsoft that's just a few minutes away
so stick around the it's the gamespot
co-op stage here at e3 2016
you